And by the time the Soviet revolution
came around,
which would be at the latter part of the
19 tens after the first world war,
the peasant class had actually
established farms,
of course,
varying productivity.
Some of the peasant farmers were very,
very good at being farmers and produced
a huge proportion of rushes and the
Ukraine's food.
Because one of the things we'll talk
about this later,
as the class progresses,
one of the things that you'll find if
that if you look at creative production
in any domain,
it doesn't matter.
Artistic Domain,
food production novels,
written novel,
Soul,
money generated,
number of companies,
generated,
number of goals,
scored in hockey,
et cetera.
Any number of paintings,
painted,
number of compositions,
written,
anything like that.
Where where the fundamental underlying
measure as human productivity,
what you find is that a very tiny
percentage of people produce almost all
of the output.
It's called a pareto distribution.
P A r e t o,
and it was studied in detail in
scientific productivity by someone named
does solar price.
It's a square root law.
So here's the law.
Fundamentally,
if you look at the number of people who
are doing,
who are,
who are in a given domain,
who are producing in a given domain,
the square root of the people produce
half the product,
so that means if you have 10 employees,
three of them do half the work,
but if you have 10,000
employees,
100 of them do half the work,
right?
It's a very,
very vicious statistic and you won't
learn about that in psychology for
reasons I have no idea about because you
learned about the normal distribution
and not the prieto distribution,
but pareto distributions govern,
for example,
the distribution of money,
which is why one percent of the people
in the general population have the
overwhelming amount of money and one
10th of that one percent has almost all
of that.
Right?
So I think it's like the richest 100
people in the world have as much money
as the bottom two and a half billion and
you think,
well that's a terrible thing,
and perhaps it is.
But what you have to understand is that
that law governs the distribution of
creative production across all creative
domains.
Right,
it's something like a natural law and we
can.
We'll talk about that more,
but imagine what happens when you play
monopoly.
You've all played monopoly.
What happens when you play monopoly?
One person ends up with all the money,
right?
Then you play another game of monopoly.
What happens?
One person ends up with all the money.
It's actually the inevitable consequence
of multiple trades that are conducted
randomly.
So if you take a thousand people and you
get them to play a trading game,
you get each give them $100,
say or $10,
and they have to trade with another
person.
By flipping a coin I.
When the coin toss you give me a dollar,
you win,
I give you a dollar.
If we all play that long enough,
one person will end up with all the
money and everyone else will end up with
zero.
So it's a deeply built feature of
systems of creative production and no
one really knows what to do about it
because of course the danger is is that
all the resources get funneled to a tiny
minority of people at the top and a huge
section of the population stacks up at
zero.
But to blame that on the oppressive
nature of a given system is to radically
underestimate the complexity of the
problem.
No one actually knows how to effectively
shovel resources from the minority that
that controls almost everything to the
majority.
That has almost nothing in any
consistent way.
Because as you shovel money down,
it tends to move right back up and it's
a big problem.
Anyways.
The reason I'm telling you about that is
because after the peasants were granted
their land and started to become
farmers,
a tiny minority of them became extremely
successful and those people produced
almost all of the food for Russia and
Ukraine.
So what happened in the 19 twenties when
bloody lennon came along and
collectivize the farms,
was that they defined the Kulaks who
were these tiny minority of successful
farmers who maybe had a brick house and
were able to hire a couple of people and
had some land in some livestock and were
very productive people.
They define them as socially unfriendly
elements and they sent groups of
intellectuals out into the towns to
collectivize the farms.
And so the idea was that while you would
pool your land and and everyone would
farm it collectively and the land was
taken away,
of course from the tiny minority of
people who are actually productive and
had actually managed to own much of the
land.
So you have to imagine how that would
occur.
Okay.
So it's in the 19 twenties,
it's after the world.
After World War One rushes in pretty bad
shape.
The villages are full of brutalized men
who have posttraumatic stress disorder
and lots of people who are not doing
well at all in the bloody intellectuals
come into the town and they say,
you know,
those successful farmers up the street
that you've always been pretty jealous
about in your useless manner while
they're actually pigs and demons who are
stealing from you.
So why don't you come out.
We'll form a nice little mob and we'll
take everything they've got.
And that's exactly what happened.
And all those people were killed or
raped or set off to Siberia in the
middle of the bloody winter where there
wasn't even anything for them to.
To anywhere for them to live or anything
for them to eat.
So they all died.
And then the consequence of that was a
few years later,
6 million people starved to death in the
Ukraine.